we have come a long way towards building
a more effective and results-oriented
cohesion policy with a maximum value for
money with an agreement today on a
partial general approach council will be
ready to start negotiations will
Parliament I would like to underline
that we support the treat of viously we
support the treatment of violin regions
as less developed regions under the erdf
I think this is extremely important for
us and I think the presidency for its
support on decision and in particular we
very much appreciate the fact that our
positions and concerns on the island
regions have been taken on board we will
receive support from the cohesion fund
and we will also support the latest
presidency proposal on the matter we
also perceived a cohesion policy from
the point of view of result and we think
it should be result-oriented that's why
we support performance framework if you
mention the islands in the allocation
method for outermost and spare sleep op
you laytah dree j'en regions you
basically open up a Pandora's box and
I'm not talking here about the all and
Islands or the United Kingdom or Malta
or Cyprus but I'm talking about alpine
regions what not and his grandmother are
basically going to be part of this whole
package so we thank the Danish
presidency war for everything they have
included in the books but one element is
still missing and I must comment on a
change that has not been made to the
books although strongly insisted by
three member states in the direct
payments of the Common Agricultural
Policy a solution for foster convergence
for member states that receive payments
significantly below European Union
average must be found for an overall
agreement just because you have quality
expenditure that doesn't mean to say
that there should be less
I think you can do a lot more with the
same amounts if those amounts are better
spent I'd like to congratulate the
Commission and the presidency on the
work they've done on the financial
framework but you know just because
spending better doesn't mean it's
necessarily spending less related to
better spending we still have serious
reservations about the proposed macro
economic condition ality the
relationship between it and the six pack
is still not clearly defined and we need
reassurances in the negotiating box the
double punishment would not be
implemented the agreement on the mff
will be a decisive political response
and it will show that here again we're
prepared to work together move together
for words and make our budgets secure
the economic crisis has had an
asymmetric effect and that should be
borne in mind when it comes to taking
decisions so our final decision should
reflect budgetary consolidation and the
asymmetric situations in our economies
we disagree with the reduction of the
weight of national prosperity with
reinforced safety nets with regions in
transition and with the urban bonus at
the same time the outermost regions are
being dealt with less well than in the
past and that is unacceptable certainly
when we talk about multi-annual
financial framework we need to
understand that this is a way to strong
and competitive European Union so we
think that multi-annual financial
framework has to concentrate on growth
jobs competitiveness and convergence I
have to restate our most important issue
in fact regrettably the sharp reduction
of our cohesion allocation is not
properly that word in in the
that's why then we will come to the text
of the conclusions I will not be able to
say that I take it the negotiating box
as a as the basis or basis but I would
like just to take note of the
negotiating box vision policy is not
just a policy it's an objective of the
European Union as a whole it is based on
the principles of fundamental solidarity
it is enshrined in our treaties and we
need to try to treat it as such for us
it is clear that the less developed
regions should receive greater support
in order to be able to catch up in their
level of development as other parts of
the European Union the tough economic
reality of the day should lead us to
first spend better not more the
expenditure level and national
contributions should be stabilized in
the next mff to reflect consolidation
efforts made by the Member States second
there is however one element and that is
the reverse safety net which I find and
you know it also very well as completely
unfair this is this is an element on
which we will not be ready to work in
the in the further negotiations we think
it's very important the box is the basis
for the negotiations going forward a
huge amount of work has been done and it
represents the point of balance and we
think it's very important that the
european council endorses that as as the
way forward there are still issues that
need to be solved considering the
negotiating box does not properly
reflect a balanced approach on certain
issues we all agree that future mff
should be oriented towards growth job
creation competitiveness and convergence
however for lavania it would be
extremely difficult to achieve these
girls with the current proposal if the
mff where an Olympic event I'm not quite
sure what it would be it certainly
wouldn't be a sprint and I have the
impression that we have been around the
track for a few laps already but we are
we are making progress and
that is thanks to to to to you very much
we'd like to say that the progressive
reduction of direct aid under the first
pillar is not acceptable for us that is
a major point of concern and we maintain
our request that we add a new
redistribution modality and direct
support between member states under the
Common Agricultural Policy we've made
real progress with the negotiating box
and on this basis we can continue to
work further but this is already a
compromise however if we don't take the
negotiating box we'd basically be
calling into question everything we've
done in the last six months it is a
precondition for timely conclusion at
the end of 2012 like Alex stub I would
agree the box is not just a basis it is
the basis for negotiation I should like
to confirm that we believe that the
presidency's negotiating box is a
balanced one I should therefore we
accept accept it as the basis for the
negotiations as has been argued this
afternoon by several others we think
that if we cannot agree on that we
should not continue to state that
negotiations can be concluded at the end
of the year we believe that it is
therefore important for the European
Council to come to this conclusion we
consider no negotiating box as a basis
for further negotiations of course there
are some elements we miss in the Box
Mike increase the convergence of the
direct payments or some measures to do
that there are some elements which we
simply don't like or are not acceptable
and I refer especially to the river
safety net on the content of the
negotiating box as it stands today I
think it's a balance the reflection of
what's being said thus far and as a
useful basis for forthcoming discussions
we remain convinced that further
discussion on the financial framework
must continue on the basis of this
negotiating box consequently we would
support the idea of the presidency
passing the box on
to the European Council any other
approach would lead to a massive delay
in slippage with our timetable thank you
it is important that the next mff will
represent both fair and effective you
budget that will aim at the delivery of
growth competitiveness and employment
especially for the youth across the
union it should encompass the necessary
means to deliver the Europe 2020 goals
why is respecting the principle of
solidarity and thus contributing to
economic and social cohesion this is a
time for action and this is a time for
decision and therefore modes are very
pleased with the words from so many
colleagues and from the firm statement
from andreas and the Cypriot presidency
that the work done by the Danish
presidency will be the port of departure
for the Cypriot presidency